PROFESSOR: Both experts and non-experts
had a role in Roman divination.
The experts were members of priestly
groups, the haruspices and the augurs.
The haurspices was
supposed to be Etruscan,
so for much of the history of ancient
Rome, this was a foreign specialism.
The haruspices had
expertise in examining
the livers of animals sacrificed
before any important occasion
and in interpreting the results.
One of the other specialisms
of the haruspices
was the interpretation of prodigies
such as eclipses, thunderbolts,
weird noises, and monstrous
births, like two headed animals.
These were seen as signs of
disorder in the natural world.
So in the case of
prodigies, we're talking
about the interpretation of
things that occur spontaneously,
not things that are done on purpose
to solicit a divine response.
The Roman Senate, made up of current
and former elected officials,
would consult the
haruspices who would give
their interpretation of the prodigies
identifying which of the gods
had been offended or what religious
offenses had been committed.
The Senate would then decide
what to do to put things right.
This combination of
particular religious expertise
and a more general level of experience
is typical of Roman prediction methods.